authorities in Tanzania say at least 19
of the 43 people on board an airplane
died after it plunged into the Waters of
Lake Victoria bad weather struck shortly
before the plane was due to land in the
Lakeside town of bukoba
with just the top of the plane still
above the Waters of Lake Victoria
Rescuers rushed to save those still on
board
emergency workers and bystanders used
ropes to try to pull the aircraft from
the water
[Music]
while some passengers could be saved for
many others their efforts came too late
the small Regional plane plunged into
Africa's largest lake as it was coming
into land at bakoba airport situated
right on the lake shore
when the aircraft was about 100 meters
mid-air it encountered problems and bad
weather it was raining and the plane
plunged into the water
everything is now under control
while officials tried to pinpoint the
exact
waves through the country
I'm joined Now by journalist Charles
combay who's in the Tanzanian city of
Dar es Salaam welcome to DW
um what do we know about the rescue
operations
well as speaking right now is that the
plane has already been moved from the
water of the Lake Victoria and as a
latest reports uh from the prime
minister of Tanzania Casi majaliwa says
that uh almost uh 19 people have been
killed in the crash and we know we all
know that we were told that for 43
people we are on the plane
but now we we are told that 19 people
have been uh died and uh previously we
are told that uh 26 people we are also
being rescued uh from the from the plane
and taken to the uh Hospital in uh
region
so as we're speaking uh the number when
you plus the numbers of the people who
were I mean who died and the number of
those who are rescued it will come to 45
so the Prime Minister uh ordered that
there should be a investigation uh to
know exactly uh the two people uh who uh
uh on that number adding to 45 people
right well um can you tell us what's
known uh perhaps or what details are
known about the cause of the crash
uh what the authorities are saying is
that the cause of the crash is a bad
weather uh when the plane was about to
land at the uh bukoba airport in the
kagero region the North Western uh parts
of Tanzania uh it crashed due to heavy
rains on the area and uh fog so uh the
plane uh uh plunged into the uh Lake
Victoria Water uh the largest uh lake in
Africa
journalist Charles Combe in darussalam
thank you
thank you